[Music]
have you guys heard of this conspiracy
theory linking the roundness with five
yes people keep telling me about alive
what do you think I think the 5g towers
is causing the rona we'd like the
cellphone five-year yeah I see it but I
don't know what they're referring to you
we're gonna have it in most places
exactly okay so that's like the easiest
way to debunk it yes if the fact that
there's countries like Iran like they
don't have 5g and they so much cheese
yeah that don't have my g 5g right now
none of us because the technology isn't
there for me yeah the signal doesn't go
very far so like let's say you need us
you need to be within like a certain
amount of feet from a tower you would
have to have a tower at every street
light pretty much why don't you put the
whole thing on right anyway what are
people saying though the how is it
connected oh because they're saying like
oh well look how convenient once they
started putting 5g towers in Wuhan it
just started spreading like crazy so
they're saying like it helps it spread
or like it makes it worse somehow
because of the radio frequency waves or
whatever but that's all [ __ ] because
the 5g network the amount of radiation
that it does emit oh they're claiming
that it weakens the immune system but
it's not even strong enough like
microwaves are stronger than 5g so radio
is yeah which is like there's certain
light of like light frequencies that are
stronger like if you look at the graph
it's still at the beginning of the graph
in terms of how strong it is compared to
like actual x-rays no people are
actually selling like well before all of
this people are selling like 5g machines
to cure headaches so like yeah so you
know like 5g that they blame out
everything for good and bad but then
they change the name of it right so it's
a certain like frequency so it's much
more rapid right and they were there
selling on Amazon stuff too you can buy
for like a couple hundred bucks it's
essentially a 5g machine that emits 5g
and then it cures headaches because
people can get headaches from like
whatever and it it helps make the
headache go away so putting yourself on
next to your head when you sleep
as long as you have the new cellphone
you like with like the whole pandemic
and I never thought that I would see
this in my lifetime but I also never
thought that people I just I swear I
feel like we're gonna walk around with
like tinfoil hats and like like stuff
they're gonna do it they're gonna do it
with the 5g fantasy I believe that would
be hilarious yeah what does cure
headaches so like the other day sleep a
bag of frozen peas peas anything your
head so numb you can't do anything well
like I was reading up so I get like
crazy like caffeine withdrawal so I'm
just so I am tap on caffeine all the
time and then so I like to wean off of
it so when I wean off of it I get like
the crazy withdrawn which is the
headache and then I was like researching
and then one of them was what said put
like something cold on your head cuz it
decreases the blood pressure and a thins
out of your blood so it doesn't throb as
much and then I put that bag of frozen
peas - you were deflation could also
just be me when you wean off it aren't
you supposed to do it like slowly so you
don't get the headache and not anybody
got time for that so that's not waiting
on me that's just cold reading I just
cool Turkey that we're all together
again a headache every week damn it
you jerky look how much coffee do
consume it I mean caffeine in order for
you to get that crazy up a headache
maybe because I take a pre-workout in
the morning to get amped every morning
what I'm training and these days is I'm
not home dude I'm training even more I'm
turning you even more than ever yeah and
so I'm taking that and then like and I
got to do a bunch of work and some
midday I'm taking it again and me and
Jill and waking up at 4:00 a.m. to do
our podcasts every day almost like every
other day just so week you guys are
machines got to do it before
Tyko wakes up cuz he wakes up at like
6:00 so Tiger wakes up early
no he sleeps at 9:00 but you know like
when you take care of kid all day like
you're just Riley goes to sleep and
you're like okay thank God he's actually
in himself and then so it's hard to go a
podcast and do
you guys have to whisper your podcast to
now wake them up too soon
well I know he has a noisemaker in his
room that's it's pretty good
oh the white noise thing yeah yeah I
hate that noise me too I hate it so yeah
it makes me not I started listening some
white noise because Google homes now you
can be like Google bedtime and it'll
start playing like forest music wow
yeah it's but yeah see I like the I like
the waterfall noise yeah it sounds like
constant pitch thank you I like it
because I like the camping sound I play
the office yeah I can do interesting me
too what happened
because I've watched it so many times so
I don't you know watch it to understand
what's going on
it's like conference I get something
every time good at every joke it's just
such a good show baby back to this 5g
stuff so there have been people like
they started tearing towers down because
they believe this and so there's a lot
of like civilians turn it down yeah
that's this whole thing though right
there attacking Asians they're like
trying to [ __ ] take down 5g they're
just doing all this stupid [ __ ] cuz
humans are [ __ ] dog you're about the
Iranian I think Iranians that drink your
alcohol because they heard that it would
like watch it like [ __ ] bleach kills
its people that died because of that
are they Muslim analogy God exactly
only for that reason they can I wasn't
allowed to drink right so then they're
saying that the people that made this
bootleg alcohol are you gonna get
severely punished because they were the
ones providing it but that's just like
people are getting desperate desperate
times
fear fear causing German Shepherds
attacked Chow house to do they thought
that's coming from a Chinese talk to you
did you Tiger got it
no like what how the [ __ ] do they even
have tests to test a damn animal but
they don't have enough test
damn Adam what was the tiger like
coughing and they're like he probably
has it isn't that scary though that now
we're able to transfer to animals well
we got it from animals but then they
said it wasn't it wasn't working back so
we couldn't transfer it thing but they
said that the virus started working in
stages can we give it to mosquitos yeah
like give mosquitoes then but feels give
two more people died before they get
this on us it's often the Weibull aronia
that's true man why the [ __ ] do we mean
those things I don't think the whole
ecosystem will yeah that's the real five
G right there's my thing already trying
to get rid of with skills like a Fabio
guys there's somebody group that wants
to keep the mosquitoes there no not
really anymore not much because they
they've tested in certain ecosystems and
they don't need mosquitoes in life force
or no dude they're not native to Hawaii
yeah yeah
so they actually uh to kill Holly are
you a problem they started doing a DNA
engineering on mosquitoes so that the
when they would make more mosquitoes
those those mosquitoes can't create more
mosquitoes a lot of those a bunch of
those in Africa and you have been having
good results they be they do completely
fine without those [ __ ] does PETA
back mosquitoes - I think pitas are they
mad they back like [ __ ] scorpions
dude they don't give up ever you dad Oh
with mosquitoes - Peter dude just have
them live in like a tropical place they
always save up don't save a cockroach
before they save a human being
don't let it [ __ ] baby rot to death
in like Doug but then if a cockroach is
like in pain they'll fight for that
cockroach anyway what just like
tender-back the people attacking the 5g
towers I wonder if they know the 5g
tower or they were just like that's a
tower let's [ __ ]
it's not even a 5g tower working on 3G
now I have nothing but people act when
they're so misinformed and they're so
violent for some time they just go crazy
dude I should show you how many stupid
[ __ ] are in this world even
celebrities like a Woody Harrelson told
he was known at Woody Harrelson I like
that what did he do it's a big duh yeah
you believed in it like hey this is
interesting and then the singer m.i.a
or meeow meeow mi mi yeah I like her
music do not hurt - so she filmed the
video outside of her apartment in the UK
and saying like they're installing a
tower right by my house like a business
gonna say they're telling us to stay
home if this is gonna be here I'm not
staying here I'm leaving and also came
out as an anti Baxter - now at this time
yay oh then she doesn't get to have one
yeah I love how people like look to
celebrities and everyone for like
scientific advice and everything yeah
though they not also let us do cocaine
like a [ __ ] brain cells are
fried like the fact that celebs have so
much eyeballs on them that they like the
drug addicts but there's some of the
most stupidest human beings for sure but
then the public or saying look you have
all this attention be responsible with
the attention you have but they're like
known for acting in movies or like
dancing or like [ __ ] singing and it's
like would you ask a [ __ ] singer
anything about medicine or whatever I
wouldn't [ __ ] listen to them that's
not their [ __ ] there's like why the [ __ ]
you want me to be a role model I get my
ass licked like what the [ __ ] dude the
the sense of like of responsibility the
power of emotion like people reason like
you're breaking down towers you're
afraid of stuff so they're they're
lashing the other I'm taking control my
fear and then they listen to celebrities
because it's comforting and they're like
I haven't listened to like
no you I've seen you like I feel like
trust them they're being honest with me
think about 5gv that's what I'm saying
well he's he's cancelled he's canceled
of the future mothers for prior to oh my
god racial fear think about 5g one of
them needs to come out and say like yeah
it's it's fivesies bad and they were but
not yeah Coolio what do you feel about
5g Coolio I should be Flavor Flav back I
know you know where's the mix where we
need them
tell us BMX if he in jail let's look up
that website like a botanist
he's like a botanist now like he's like
like a lamp yeah plants and all that
yeah so I'm going off or like he's like
here's a green house at first I thought
you needed like a really expensive soil
top with what you going is like what you
thought can turn that voice but you
gotta think I have the road is guitar
like that times first but he was like
where do they grow as a botanist I'm
curious is Oh will you get the tulips
you gotta be delicate
[Music]
[Music]